C'est bientôt
Noël et je sais que certains parmi vous
espèrent trouver un nouveau smartphone
au pied du sapin.
Boh... Comment tu sais ce que j'ai mis
sur ma liste !?
Je lis dans tes pensées.
Bon, ce n'est pas très compliqué,
l'année dernière,
il s'est vendu en France 16 millions
de téléphones portables,
avec un pic de ventes au mois de décembre.
Mais une fois les paquets déballés,
que faire de l'ancien modèle ?
Allez, suivez-moi.
Je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
il faut recycler nos anciens
téléphones portables.
On a du mal aujourd'hui
à imaginer notre quotidien
sans ce petit appareil.
Et pourtant,
les premiers téléphones portables
commercialisés en France
datent seulement des années 80.
Portable portable, faut le dire
vite, et t'as pas vu celui-là.
Il est vrai
que les premiers téléphones dits mobiles
pesaient plusieurs kilogrammes et qu'on
les installait plutôt dans les voitures.
Il coûtait aussi une petite fortune.
À la fin des années 1990,
les appareils
se sont considérablement améliorés,
le réseau aussi, et des téléphones comme celui-ci
se sont vendus comme des petits pains.
Le nombre d'abonnés
aux téléphones portables explose.
Parti de zéro ou presque
au début des années 1990,
il atteint 30 millions
à la fin de l'année 2000.
Et ce n'est que le début de l'histoire.
Dans les années 2000 :
révolution !
On commence à surfer sur Internet
avec nos téléphones
et en 2007,
ils deviennent carrément intelligents.
Des "smartphones".
Ils permettent de partager des photos,
de lire des vidéos,
de faire des achats en ligne,
d'envoyer des mails, des messages,
ils ont un GPS, bref,
ils savent tout faire.
Mais là-dessus,
je ne vous apprendrai rien.
Oui ? Et on peut même téléphoner avec ! Oui, merci.
Aujourd'hui, deux Français sur trois
sont équipés de ces téléphones
devenus des ordinateurs de poche
et dont la technologie continue d'évoluer
très vite, et ce sont les fréquentes mises
à jour des logiciels qui nous poussent
à acheter les modèles dernier cri.
Du coup, nous changeons de téléphone
en moyenne tous les deux ans et dans 88%
des cas, l'ancien fonctionne encore.
Alors très souvent,
on garde nos vieux appareils
au fond des tiroirs.
C'est vrai que depuis 1996,
j'en ai accumulé quelques-uns.
On a tous tendance à les garder au cas où,
si le nouveau téléphone tombait en panne
ou parce qu'ils ont acquis
une valeur sentimentale.
Alors, ma première déclaration
d'amour par texto,
mon premier selfie de vacances,
ma première vidéo YouTube.
Résultat entre 30 et 100 millions
de vieux téléphones
dorment dans nos placards.
C'est bien dommage,
car ces appareils cachent des trésors.
On parle même de mines urbaines
dans nos tiroirs. Oh, t'exagères.
Il est pas si profond que ça ce tiroir...
Pour comprendre de quoi il retourne,
il faut regarder
sous le capot du téléphone.
Prenons
un smartphone de base comme celui-ci
et regardons ce qui se cache
derrière son écran bien lisse.
On voit tout d'abord
la batterie, qui occupe beaucoup d'espace.
Il y a également
le capteur de l'appareil photo,
le processeur,
le modem pour se connecter à Internet,
la carte mémoire, le micro, le vibreur,
l'antenne cellulaire.
Il y a de plus en plus de composants.
Derrière toute cette technologie,
il y a énormément de matières premières.
70 kg pour produire un seul téléphone.
Autrement dit, 600 fois son poids.
Si on simplifie la recette,
voici les différents ingrédients
avec lesquels on le fabrique. Du verre
et de la céramique,
entre 10 et 20% des ingrédients,
principalement pour l'écran. Du plastique
et des matières synthétiques,
30 à 50%. Et enfin,
des métaux qui représentent 40 à 60%
des matériaux.
Le problème, c'est que certains de
ces métaux sont rares et précieux.
Chaque téléphone contient
une cinquantaine de métaux,
dont ceux qu'on appelle les terres rares.
Ils ont des noms qu'on croirait sortis
de livres de science fiction. L'yttrium,
le terbium, l'europium... L'expression
terres rares prête à confusion
car ces éléments ne sont pas rares
sur notre planète,
mais ils sont difficiles à détecter
et à extraire des minerais
qui les contiennent.
En plus, comme beaucoup de composants
de nos téléphones,
ils ne viennent pas de la porte à côté.
La plupart des
gisements de terres rares
se situent loin de notre continent.
Dans des pays qui n'ont pas les mêmes
normes environnementales et sociales
que l'Europe.
Ces métaux sont aujourd'hui indispensables
pour la fabrication des smartphones.
Le problème, c'est
que leur extraction est très polluante.
Elle utilise beaucoup d'eau et d'énergie.
Au final, si l'on met bout à bout
toutes les distances parcourues
par les différents éléments qui
le composent, un smartphone fait un, deux,
trois, quatre fois le tour du monde
avant d'arriver dans notre poche.
Tout cela n'est pas très réjouissant,
mais j'ai une bonne nouvelle.
Le smartphone le plus écologique,
c'est celui que vous avez déjà.
Car le meilleur compromis
pour l'environnement,
c'est de faire durer son téléphone
le plus longtemps possible.
Et pour ça, il y a quelques astuces.
C'est souvent à cause d'un écran abîmé
qu'on change de modèle.
Alors,
investir dans une protection d'écran
et une coque, c'est déjà un grand pas
pour faire durer son téléphone.
Si vous prévoyez partir à l'aventure,
sachez aussi qu'il existe
des modèles étanches.
Pour que votre batterie ne s'épuise pas,
il faut la bichonner.
Idéalement, il faut la mettre en charge
avant qu'elle ne soit complètement vide.
La plupart des modèles
vous alertent d'ailleurs lorsque son
niveau baisse en dessous de 20%.
Eh bien, c'est le bon moment
pour la brancher.
À l'inverse,
mieux vaut la débrancher dès qu'elle est
pleine. On évite de la laisser en charge
toute la nuit, par exemple.
Attention aussi aux surchauffes.
Après une phase d'utilisation intense
lorsqu'on joue à un jeu en réseau
par exemple, ou qu'on utilise le GPS,
il faut laisser refroidir l'appareil.
Et évidemment, on ne l'oublie pas
au soleil ou près d'un radiateur.
Enfin, sachez que si votre téléphone
a moins de deux ans,
il est encore couvert
par sa garantie légale.
Donc, avant d'en acheter un neuf, tentez
de le faire réparer. S'il est bien utilisé,
un smartphone peut fonctionner
pendant au moins quatre ans.
Alors évidemment, il arrive un moment
où votre fidèle
compagnon ne peut plus être réanimé...
Mais pas question de l'enterrer au fond du jardin.
On l'a dit,
les téléphones contiennent des matières
précieuses qui peuvent être récupérées.
Aujourd'hui, seuls 15% des téléphones
sont collectés pour être recyclés.
Et pourtant, ce n'est pas bien compliqué.
Plastique, verre, métal, je le mets
dans quel bac mon vieux téléphone ?
Dans aucun de ceux-là,
à cause de leur batterie inflammable,
les téléphones portables sont considérés
comme des déchets dangereux.
Alors, où les met-on ?
Eh bien, des bornes dédiées
existent en magasins.
Les lieux de vente ont l'obligation
de les reprendre avec leurs accessoires.
Si vous n'en avez pas près de chez vous,
vous pouvez commander
une enveloppe prépayée ou imprimer
gratuitement une étiquette sur le site :
Jedonnemontelephone.fr
et votre vieux smartphone sera dirigé
vers la bonne adresse.
Et maintenant, en route,
on va aller voir très concrètement
ce que deviennent nos vieux smartphones.
Hey, attends-moi.
Une fois vos téléphones collectés,
ils restent en France
et sont envoyés dans des sites agréés
comme celui-ci.
Ils y sont triés.
Ceux qui fonctionnent encore
sont reconditionnés pour être revendus.
Rassurez-vous, toutes les données
personnelles sont effacées auparavant.
J'espère bien parce qu'il
y a toutes mes photos de vacances.
De cette manière,
entre 5 et 15% des téléphones
peuvent être remis en circulation,
ce qui évite la fabrication
d'autant de nouveaux téléphones
et la pollution
qui accompagne cette fabrication.
Pour les autres, c'est par là-bas
que ça se passe,
suivez-moi.
Quand c'est possible,
on récupère des pièces détachées
qui serviront à prolonger la vie
d'autres téléphones, mais quand il n'y
a vraiment plus rien à sauver,
on sort les grands moyens
pour récupérer les matières précieuses.
Les composants sont séparés puis broyés,
les métaux ferreux sont récupérés
grâce à des aimants
et les cartes électroniques sont mises
de côté
pour subir un sort encore plus radicale.
Ciao.
Là, je me suis équipé,
un peu comme si j'allais sur un volcan,
car la température est très élevée ici
aux alentours de 1100 degrés.
C'est à cette température
que les cartes électroniques
de nos téléphones
sont en train de fondre à l'intérieur,
de se creuser.
Et voilà le résultat,
de la grenaille éclatée.
Allô ?
Il n'y a plus personne au bout du fil.
Alors à ce stade,
tous les métaux sont encore mélangés.
Pour les séparer les uns des autres,
on va passer cette grenaille
dans différents bains d'acide.
Mais c'est vraiment de la torture,
c'est horrible...
Je sais mais... c'est pour la bonne cause.
Ce n'est pas terminé.
Pour récupérer les métaux purifiés,
on va placer des électrodes dans ces cuves
et faire circuler un courant électrique.
Le métal vient se déposer sur ces plaques,
la cathode et les impuretés
tombent au fond.
On récupère ensuite ce métal
qui va de nouveau être fondu
pour être plus facilement utilisable.
En faisant fondre
une tonne de cartes électroniques,
on peut récupérer jusqu'à 1,2 kg d'argent,
250 kg de cuivre et 400 grammes d'or.
C'est 40 fois
plus que dans les meilleures mines du monde.
Les métaux récupérés sont aussi purs
que ceux qui sortent d'une mine et
ils peuvent être réutilisés
pour fabriquer de nouveaux téléphones.
Mais il reste quelques limites
au recyclage.
Nos fameuses terres rares
sont présentes en très faible quantité
dans nos téléphones
et les procédés de recyclage
restent beaucoup plus chers
que l'extraction minière.
D'autres métaux, comme l'acier,
sont aussi plus difficiles à purifier
et ne pourront plus servir à fabriquer
des produits électroniques.
Ils partent donc vers d'autres industries.
Dans l'automobile, par exemple,
ils serviront à fabriquer
des culasses
ou des collecteurs d'échappement.
Enfin, certains composants
sont trop mélangés et on n'a pas
d'autre choix que de les brûler
et de récupérer l'énergie produite.
La demande pour
ces métaux éthiques et écologiques
est en plein boom.
Plus on sera nombreux
à déposer nos téléphones, plus on pourra
augmenter la part de matériaux recyclés
dans leur fabrication
et créer une filière complète en France
avec des emplois à la clé.
Rien que sur ce site,
chaque année, ce sont
8500 tonnes de métaux qui sont récupérés.
Allez, un dernier chiffre
si 100 personnes déposent leurs portables.
Ce sont 170 kg de matières économisées
et près d'une
tonne de CO2 dans l'atmosphère.
Allez, on rentre à l'atelier.
Récapitulons.
On ne craque pas sur le dernier modèle
à la mode.
On fait durer son téléphone
le plus longtemps possible et on recycle
ceux qui ne fonctionnent plus.
Et lorsque l'on doit changer d'appareil,
on choisit le bon.
Un nouveau téléphone ne veut pas
nécessairement dire un téléphone neuf.
On trouve aujourd'hui
de nombreux modèles reconditionnés.
Sachez que qu'un Français sur quatre a
déjà acheté un smartphone de seconde main.
Il vous paraît
un peu absurde d'acheter un quatre-quatre
pour rouler en ville ? Et bien avec le téléphone
c'est la même chose !
Choisir en fonction de ses besoins réels,
c'est faire un geste pour la planète.
Gardez en tête que plus l'écran est grand,
plus il y a de composants
et plus le téléphone pollue
lors de sa fabrication.
Allô ? Allô ?
Pour qu'il dure longtemps,
vérifiez que votre téléphone
a un indice de réparabilité élevé.
Cette note, qui va de 1 à 10,
vous assure que l'appareil
pourra être facilement réparé.
Le plus compliqué dans cette histoire,
c'est sûrement
de savoir où on a rangé ses vieux
téléphone.
Allez, salut les Epicurieuses
et les Epicurieux !
Je crois qu'une petite chasse au trésor
vous attend.
Tout ça
n'est pas très réjouissant, mais dommage.
Et regardons ce qui se cache.
Dommage.
Bon, ce n'est pas très compliqué.
Je reprends.